[Music]
hello everyone this is the daily Deni
live it is Friday which means we are one
day away from the royal wedding I'm
Denny direct oh this is so busy Laci and
we have everything you guys need to know
before Prince Harry and mega Markel say
I do tomorrow I can't believe it
bye leaves how excited we're ready for
it we're really excited you guys and of
course today is the last day that Harry
and Megan are waving goodbye to that
single life the couple actually arrived
to Windsor Castle where the wedding will
take place today for their last wedding
or so we actually have a shot of them
arriving together and take a look at
this you guys they are absolutely
glowing like II look so happy
so happy I mean I'm assuming there's
gotta be some last-minute nerves and
obviously there's been a lot of stuff
bleeding a lot of drama going up to this
big day but look at her yeah is so ready
- no sign of stress no no sign of stress
at all I'm so excited from that picture
alone to be part of the royal family in
my opinion yeah you know yeah and you
know what candids are not always
flattering no she's so regal like she
knows how to pose for those photons
cheese oh yeah so like I mention you
guys Windsor Castle is where the wedding
will take place fans have been lined up
for the last couple days now and in fact
this morning Prince Harry and his best
man Prince William walked the crowd
shook hands kissing babies and that is
where our very own Kevin Frazier got
Harry and asked him how he's feeling
before the big day
take a look
are you ready are you ready Harry are
you ready everybody asking him how he's
feeling not surprisingly he certainly
didn't look remotely now right I don't
have Kevin Frazier getting right in
there there you go no Kevin he is the
king yeah we call the hallway interview
you know but that's amazing amazing
amazing
obviously they went to go visit the fans
there and like I mentioned you guys they
have been lined up and camped out for a
really long time just for a sight of
Harry let alone Megan and I something
tells me they'll be there tomorrow but
you know right now we are gonna toss it
over to lauren zima with also outside
windsor castle to capture all the royal
fanfare fascinators and all lauren i'm
lauren zima we have made it to windsor
everybody and i am in full fascinator
mode I'm not taking this thing off Harry
and Megan's big day is almost here and
preparations are fully underway there's
everything from tchotchkes and flair to
police and dishware
[Music]
still pretty jet-lagged so thanks Rachel
Rick we need more castle footage
sweeping shots of the castle or castle
all the castle is a castle in it should
be mostly castle I got it I might be
standing outside the castle but people
have been camping outside of it and we
found out what motivates these hairy and
ugly fans and that's a person sleeping
on the sidewalk where does the passion
come from what drives you to camp
outside the royal wedding it's hard to
say just we love the royal family just
really really no Trent I love Megan and
it's just excited to get a mini Princess
Carole are you cold I'm Persian
well I'm warming up now but have you
been sleeping out here yes
two nights nights and you have one more
two more two more and last night was
coated with each other work yes we are
question where do you guys go to use the
restroom a shower mcdonnell's and things
that guy hurries played the field many
times we've all waited patiently and if
these men was this who would really be
proud of him we love love
love his braids you wore your Harry and
Megan mast in the castle who was Harry
and he was Megan that's the question
well I was Megan she was Harry but how
did you feel about mom making you be
Harry I think I look kind of like Harry
yeah I see I see it was okay they've got
their swag but we've got ours oh yeah oh
the dog is named Camila so you like my
hat you approach you are really
appropriate guys I've just had a thought
it's really hitting me right now I mean
if you're Megan Markel one day you're
doing yoga and the next your face is on
a shortbread tin it's weird do you think
I could slip into the wedding unnoticed
you could trolley there's a lot of
military presence here stupid yes a lot
of big guns yeah yeah we can't get past
that you teach me one British phrase
that I shouldn't use why I'm here in
Windsor Tony could you show it's gonna
be a jolly good show at the wedding yeah
jolly good show a jolly good show we're
about to see the military rehearsal
jolly good show
[Music]
so far the military rehearsal has been a
lot of guns and some left-right-left but
we've heard a carriage is coming
[Music]
we could not get any closer everybody we
are right at the base of Windsor Castle
[Music]
the magic of television shout-out to
Laurie also Ricardo our crew member you
guys have been killing a jolly good show
so much I wouldn't know what kind of
slag they're coming back oh you know she
has a second bag pass mugs the Queen's
face it's gonna be great as you guys
could tell from that clip rehearsals and
preparations for the procession have
been well underway before the big
ceremony tomorrow but of course the big
question on everybody's mind has been
who will walk Megan Marco down the aisle
tomorrow is the million dollar question
Danny all right we have some answer do
okay so Megan put an end to the
cliffhanger that was all the drama
surrounding her dad Thomas Markel was he
going to the wedding was he not so Megan
issued a rare statement on Thursday
saying sadly my father will not be
attending our wedding I have always
cared for my father and hope he can be
given the space he needs to focus on his
health Megan's dad of course is
recovering reportedly from heart surgery
all this amid some paparazzi photo drama
where it looked like he had staged some
photos and it was just a whole thing so
a lot of people were thinking maybe
Megan's mother would walk her down the
aisle myself included not so today
another statement was released from the
palace said Miss Megan Markel has asked
His Royal Highness the Prince of Wales
that's Prince Charles to accompany her
down the aisle of the choir of st.
George's Chapel on her wedding day
the Prince of Wales is pleased to be
able to welcome miss Marcal to the royal
family in this way did this take you by
surprise that Prince Charles her
father-in-law would be walking her down
okay so a lot of people did suspect that
this might be happening I was still
holding out hope for her mom you know
it's not like a super traditional
wedding they are breaking with tradition
and they are breaking with tradition
here as well I'll explain that in a
minute
but I wanted this girl power moment with
her mom
I just feel like she doesn't even really
know Charles that well probably I you
know what it's just a lot to ask of her
mother to walk her down the aisle in
this huge huge moment I feel like
because clearly Megan was the one to ask
I think she was doing it with a purpose
you know no man I think she want to
maybe cut her mom a break who is not
someone who is used to being in the
spotlight that very way you know to me I
feel like not only is this an amazing
symbol of like of Megan becoming part of
the royal family but I also feel like
Prince Charles is the one who could
totally calm her nerves right yeah I
think he is he seems so regal you know
what I mean yes we go like can you
imagine her him just whispering
something or ear in that British accent
that just got totally blocks out any of
that noise I just feel like he I feel
like if it wasn't her mother it should
be him and I'm going to tip that calming
father present I I kind of would have
liked to see William do it okay if they
were gonna have a member of the world do
it I I don't know okay yeah and you know
what it is that is fair I hadn't thought
about that maybe her mother was nervous
and her mother didn't want to do it it's
a lot to have someone who's not used to
being in the media like this well here's
how it's gonna go down according to CNN
Megan will begin the bridal processional
on escorted social walk down by herself
to start followed by her bridesmaids and
pageboys then Prince Charles is gonna
join her once she reaches the choir
which is the area where the main royal
guests are gonna be seated so we're all
the the action is really happening
they're saying here they're clear to say
that he will not quote give her away
that's not his role he's just
accompanying her and he will actually
stand back from Megan as she approaches
Harry at the altar by herself which I do
think is an appropriate way to
absolutely yeah so then that way they're
breaking tradition right they are this
is very unusual well we've been told one
tradition that they are upholding is
that Harry and Megan will spend the
night apart tonight yeah yeah they want
to uphold that tradition you don't need
that bad luck Harry that's great not at
this point oh don't don't take 90
chances so Harry you spend the night
with his best man William
and Megan will be spending a night with
her mother and speaking of her mother
Doria Raglan
we've been told that she met the Queen
today at Windsor Castle over some tea
she actually has met the rest of the
royal family over the past week so she
met Prince William and Kate Middleton
and their children on Thursday and
Prince Charles and his wife Camilla met
Megan's mother during tea at Clarence
House on Wednesday
we're told that miss Raglan felt
incredibly welcomed and thoroughly
enjoyed it so yeah I'm sure they're
welcome me welcoming making the mother
with open arms to the UK for sure yeah
and there's a lot of people coming into
the UK right now a lot of famous royal
wedding guests a source tells et that
Elton John will play at the reception
not a bad performer no and we're told
that he plans to sing and there's also
been some sort of talk of a tribute to
Princess Diana which would be so fitting
and of course he's a longtime friend of
the late Princess died there's a photo
of them right there that's right that
would be amazing I love that Annie she
has also learned that James Corden is
attending the wedding don't think he's
gonna be pulling any carpool karaoke
stanza you never know James Corden will
be there with his wife and a source
close to the Clooney's tells us that a
mall is spec is expected to be there
excuse me George though is still up in
the air
yeah I believe he's shooting catch-22
right now so busy but he time for Royal
Wedding they actually Megan's best
friends Priyanka Chopra and Serena
Williams were also spotted landing at
Heathrow Airport in London so you put
two and two together and soon they're
here for the big day as well and we've
been seeing your suits co-star Patrick
jams
exactly seen as Wow everyone's trickling
in yawn we got our eyes on the ground of
course team et is on the ground in
London and we're bringing back so much
coverage tomorrow for the royal wedding
I know a lot of you guys been asking how
can you watch it well
CBS and is livestream in the ceremony
and you can catch that on e t online.com
or you can watch the coverage live on
CBS it'll be hosted by CBS this
morning's Gayle King any T's very own
Kevin Frazier the service and the
coverage starts promptly at 4:00 a.m.
Pacific and 7 & 8 7:00 a.m. Eastern let
me repeat that in the United States if
you want to watch the Royal Wedding you
got to get up real early or catch it
later 4:00 a.m. Pacific 7:00 a.m.
Eastern and et Online will also be live
blogging will be live blogging the whole
thing guys on et online.com starting at
4:00 a.m. and if that wasn't enough your
friends here Danny and Sophie we will be
back here for daily Denny tomorrow at 6
a.m. Pacific 9:00 a.m. Eastern for a
live recap of this what is I'm expecting
to be an amazing amazing global event
and of course beautiful wedding ceremony
so I'm so excited it's very early early
but you know what we're gonna we're
gonna have our game faces on we're gonna
start where English tea a tea and then
maybe we'll end with a glass of
champagne a toast to the bread group I
did it again
Sophie I'm sorry bring some sparkling
grape juice that's okay yes and I just
want to say a shout out to you know for
people who maybe aren't into waking up
at 4:00 a.m. to watch the wedding that's
fair um ET online comm will have so much
more coverage will have photo galleries
news articles video so if you want to
catch up at a normal human hour of being
woken up at Saturday you can go ahead
and check out ET online calm the
highlights one more plug guys if you are
waking up early to watch this wedding
yesterday we showed you how to throw an
amazing view on wedding viewing party
that's up on e t--'s youtube channel and
on ET online.com alright I think we got
enough out thank you guys so much for
joining us all week long for our
coverage of the Royal Wedding as I
mentioned we will be back live tomorrow
at 6 a.m. Pacific can't wait you guys
it's gonna be an amazing amazing love
affair I can't wait to see it alright
guys well take it easy and we'll see you
tomorrow morning
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]